Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm here with a return guest, Dr. Suki
Finn. She's now an associate professor in social philosophy
at Royal Holloway University of London. And today we're
going to talk about her book What's in the
Donutt Hole and Other philosophical Food for Thought in
our, just to say that in our first interview,
we talked about the epistemology of logic, the philosophy
of love, and the metaphysics of pregnancy, and I
will be leaving a link to it in the
description down below. And Dr. Finn, welcome back to
the show. It's always a pleasure to talk with
you.
Oh, thank you so much for having me back.
It's really nice to see you again.
Yes, so I mean, before we get into the
actual questions that you explore in your book, how
did you come up with this idea of exploring
and presenting philosophical questions through food metaphors?
Yeah, so I really wanted to bring philosophy kind
of down to earth and make the questions that
it asks more tangible and accessible for as many
people as possible. So it kind of functions like
an introduction to philosophy through food. And the reason
I chose food is because. Um, IT'S the closest
to a commonplace experience that I could think of.
Um, WE all have some interaction with food, it
seems. Um, AND we all think, and so thinking
about food or thinking through food, um, was a
way for me to make philosophy relatable. Um, SO
the food analogies that run through the book, they
function a bit like a Trojan horse for philosophy,
if you like, or, um, a spoonful of sugar
that helps the philosophy go down. Um, BECAUSE otherwise,
philosophy, it tends to operate. In the realm of
the abstract and abstract ideas can be quite hard
to get your head around, um, I found. And
so what I do in the book is each
chapter, um, I utilize a different food scenario to
bring out some abstract philosophical puzzle.
Yeah, even though I have to say that you
have to be a little bit careful because this
might ruin some people's meals.
Yeah, if you think too much, you might, well,
it might actually increase your appetite because you're working
hard with all, all the thinking. So
yeah, but, but I mean, I'm going to eat
a pizza. Is this still a pizza? Is this
not a pizza anymore? What I'm eating here, you
know, but for people who particularly suffer from OCD,
this might become very complicated.
Yeah, well, that's another like entirely different and very
important um and serious topic, yeah.
OK, so let's start with actually uh what were
you allude to in the title of your book.
So what are holes and is a hole something
that exists or not?
Yeah, so, so that question, it, um, it's what
I talk about in the very title chapter of,
um, of the book, the first chapter of the
book on doughnuts, using doughnuts. So, um, when we
consider, say, a, a ring shaped doughnut, um, we
might perceive a hole in it, um, and refer
to it as a doughnut with a hole. Um,
BUT when we ask questions about the nature of
that hole. Um, OR as you've done, the, the
very reality of, of holes in general, then we'll
come to wonder what it is that we're actually
perceiving and referring to, um, especially if those holes
can be explained away or reduced to something else.
Yeah, yeah, because I mean we actually talk about
holes, right, but it's as if there's nothing there.
I mean, I guess we could say there's air
there unless it's a hole in a vacuum or
something, but I mean, how do philosophers tend to
conceptualize holes and do they think about The as
existing things, non-existing things, and later we're going to
talk a little bit more about what is, uh,
what is it for something to exist and what
is a non-existent thing, but how do philosophers tend
to think about holes?
Yeah, they're all very related topics actually um and
there are many different philosophical approaches uh to holes
or uh gaps or absences. So we can think
of them as things in themselves um or the
the word whole, for example, is just a name
for where something is not. So we've applied a
name to refer to something that actually is otherwise
not there. So um in the case of the
doughnut, say, um, the question is whether the whole
is a part of the doughnut or just where
there is no dough in the middle. Um, SO
take uh if you're trying to make a list
of all the things in reality, some sort of
like book of the world as some metaphysicists would
say, the question would be. With doughnuts on that
list, are there, um, as well as the dough,
also the holes on that list. Um, AND if
we keep filling that list with all the things
that exist, what happens to the gaps in between
all of those things, if indeed there are. ARE
any gaps once we've listed all the things because
as you mentioned, the vacuum, even the vacuum, um,
might not be one of those gaps because in
a vacuum, it's not that there's pure emptiness, there's
still a field, you know, underlying. Um, SO there
isn't really one a place that we get to
once we've taken absolutely everything away, um. So the
question of how we conceptualize or understand um these
gaps or the spaces between things is a very
interesting question. Um, WE could pose it as whether
we're dealing with the absence of presence, like the
absence of material, or that there's a presence of
absence. And these are like two kind of alternative
ways of trying to to grapple with with holes.
Yeah, even though there's also those American doughnuts that
do not have holes, so perhaps this might get
people thinking that when they pay for a doughnut
with a hole, they're getting ripped off or something
because they're getting less doughnuts.
Yeah, yeah, I mean that's certainly uh a joke
that I've heard uh be said a lot. You're
getting like with a a moose, for example, what
you're paying for so much or what you're consuming
is a lot of air, um, what's not really
there. So, um, but of course that plays a
a role in the culinary experience um without those
spaces. It becomes a very different sort of food,
um, and a very, so it has this this
aesthetic role, um, that for some foods I suppose
is essential to its very being, um, like the
bagel or the polo or the ring shaped doughnut.
Um, THESE, uh, foods with holes in wouldn't be
what they are without that shape.
Mhm. Yeah. Uh, AND we're, I, I think we're
going to come back to that question later, but,
uh, what is then, what is it then for
something uh to exist? I mean, how do philosophers
tend to approach these uh uh this of course.
Is a metaphysical question. Uh, WHAT is it for
something to exist and um how do we determine
that something exists or is non-existent? I mean, how
do we approach those kinds of questions?
Yeah, so you say that this is metaphysical, but
in a way you could see it as meta
metaphysical. Um, AND I, I love the metas. Um,
I'm always adding them on. Um, SO like the,
the metaphysical question is asking whether holes exist, whereas
the meta metaphysical question. Um, IS, as you've just
posed, what it means for holes or anything to
exist. What our account of existence even is. And,
um, we might think that we should take to
exist all the things that play some irreducible role
in causation or explanation. Um, OR all the things
that we can't help but refer to in our
best theories or understandings of the world. Um, BUT
when it comes to holes or absences or gaps,
um, why I think that those things don't meet
that criteria. Um, AND why I think that those
criteria are the right ones and haven't been kind
of formed with a positivist kind of bias towards,
um, or against certain negative entities. So it's hard
to know where to start your, um, your analysis.
Yeah, but, but I mean, even when we talk
about something as being non-existent, if we approach metaphysics
or meta metaphysics through a framework that is not
strict. Materialistic. I mean, if just by the fact
that we are talking about non-existent things, wouldn't that
make those non-existent things existing things, at least on
the conceptual level.
Yeah, yeah, that's it's a really uh important question
actually. Um, SO there are there are many examples
I suppose that people go to in order to
motivate that there are nonexistent things or maybe to
put it more palatably, that there are some things
that do not exist. um AND you might put
on that side um the immaterial stuff. Um, OR
past things, future things, merely possible things, impossible things,
fictional things. Um, BUT the question is, as you've
just said, like whether in order to be qualified
as a thing at all, in order to the
very process of conceptualizing it as a thing, does
that mean that it has come into existence in
some. Very basic sense, um, such that we can
never really get to that dark side, um, because
we're always bringing it into our purview of existence.
So, like with holes, um, we kind of struggle
when we attempt to push everything through this positive
framework, um, that ends up kind of ridding of
negative entities by making them exist in some positive
way just by virtue of attending to them.
Mhm. Yeah, uh, because I, I mean, uh, when
it comes to, uh, metaphysics, and sometimes I think
this also intersects a little bit with epistemology, uh,
the, there are things like Ideas that I mean
even in even lay people talk about ideas as
if they are things that exist that they they
are not strictly materialist things, but we tend to
talk about them as if they existed,
right. Yeah, so it might be that the materialist
approach to reality is inadequate, given that we might
be able to come up with examples like these
that demonstrate that our reality is made up of
far more than um the stuff of material. Um,
SO yeah, pick your favorite example, whether they be
ideas or numbers or some other sort of abstract
immaterial object. Either you paraphrase them away into trying
to reduce them into something material or you take
them at face value and you adopt a metaphysics
that can accommodate for these alternative ways of being.
Yeah, I mean, I guess that from a neuroscientific
perspective, you could be a reductionist and say that
actually ideas is just patterns of firings in your
brain or something like that, so they are actually
material. It's just that we have these more so.
Sort of a non-material view of it, a sort
of more idealistic view of it of them if
you will, because we use language to express them
and we have thoughts about them and so on,
which I mean don't seem to be strictly material,
but you know.
Yeah, yeah. And but there's also, again, that meta
metaphysical question as to whether reduction is something that
gets you closer to to truth. So just, um,
assuming that because something reduces to something else. Um,
THAT something else is the only thing that exists
and the thing that was reduced does not. You
know, that's, that's an assumption that can be challenged
in itself. And so trying to articulate what um
exists and what doesn't, what's real and what isn't.
Um, JUST by virtue of what's irreducible, um, that
might be the wrong approach. And again it might
be an approach that's already biased, um, in favor
of one sort of entity over another. So one
of the great things about philosophy is that you
can challenge all of these assumptions all the way.
And there's nothing that really isn't up for grabs.
So, um, so yeah, the questions continue.
Yeah, no, and that's the most fascinating, fascinating aspect
of philosophy, at least as far as I'm concerned.
So, but let me ask you then, because this
is also something that you explore in your book,
what is nothing? And I guess that that this
is a relevant question that also applies to, for
example, discussions in physics about whether the universe came
from nothing, because then we have To discuss what
nothing is and what it means for something to
come from nothing and if nothing is really possible,
I mean if there's, if there could be nothing,
I mean, it's it's these are very tricky questions,
but how do philosophers tend to approach them?
Yeah, um, so nothingness is, is one of my
favorite, uh, examples, I suppose one of my favorite
negative entities. Um, um, AND by thinking about nothing,
we kind of rerun some of the questions that
we've already discussed, some of the issues that we've
already discussed with holes, um, being things or just
where things are not. Likewise with nothing, if it's
a thing or where there are no. Things, um,
because by definition, it seems like its name implies
that it is no thing, but us talking about
nothingness brings it into being as some sort of
thing that we can discuss and question and analyze
and refer to and describe. Um, SO we kind
of end up in contradiction with ourselves sometimes and
when we make a thing out of no thing.
Um, AND this gets us into some of my
favorite philosophical playgrounds of, uh, like Mainonianism, which is
a theory that there are non-existent things, um, and
dialetheism, which is a theory that there are some
true contradictions, um, and even Buddhism on emptiness, uh,
which is very relevant for understandings of nothingness. Um,
AND these do, as, as you say, crop up
a lot in my book. Um, BECAUSE they bring
out some really, uh, fascinating paradoxes, um, that cross
logic, metaphysics, language, as you mentioned, physics as well,
mathematics, set theory, um, I have this idea that
we can. Conceptualize what we mean when we're talking
about nothing as a thing, as being, um, nothing
as being the empty set, where what is in
the empty set are no members, no things. So
we kind of give this name um to the
set of nothing um or the set of no.
Things we give this name Nothing with a capital
N, um, as a, uh, a noun also almost,
um, for this quantitative absence of no things there.
So yeah, it's, it crosses all sorts of disciplines
in a in a very interesting way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and, and another interesting thing, at
least for me when it comes to discussing nothing
is that if we're discussing it in the domain
of physics, for example, and we're talking about the
origins of the universe and whether it came from
nothing or it came from something, is that, uh
I mean it runs against the limits. Myths of
our cognition as humans because I mean if you
try to imagine nothing, I mean literally nothing, I,
I think that the best we can do is
imagining a space that is completely black, but that's
also not exactly nothing. It's like we're imagining the
color or the absence of color. As black, but
that's, I mean, that's not what physicists mean by
nothing. It's something that we just as humans have
a cognitive limitation when it comes to conceptualizing or
imagining it,
right? Yeah, absolutely. It does push us to the
limits of cognition, to the limits of our language,
um, and um. I think like as you mentioned
with physics, their their understanding of the vacuum also
probably wouldn't match up with the most er nothingines
of what a philosopher might mean when they talk
of nothingness. Um, SO something coming from nothing, well,
um, it depends. If you're nothing still has, has
a field going on, um, this is, which is
why I kind of like thinking about it through
the notion of an empty set because even once
you've got rid of all the members and you've
taken away everything that you can from your set,
you're still left with a set. Um, AND that's
kind of as far as we can go. Like
what do you get when you remove. The empty
set or even with with zero, take it, um,
as uh that's a very, for me, curious and
fascinating number that, um, in a way functions more
like a symbol, um, though that like is a
very controversial thing to say, I suppose. Um, BUT
in our very trying to even picture, um, zero
or like. The absence of a number, we've we've
kind of drawn a circle around where there is
no thing there to try, we, we try so
hard to pin down and talk about nothingness in
all of these ways and in doing so we
mark out something. That becomes something that we the
the when you're mentioning about coming up against the
limits of our cognition and the limits of our
language, I think those limits we end up transcending
or trying to transcend them um in contradictory ways
by um. Turning towards something that is constantly evading
us, um, and yeah, this is how we end
up in contradictions and in paradoxes and maybe that
tells us something very important about reality that um.
That it is more complex than than we can
comprehend and maybe contradiction is something that is inescapable.
Um, SO yeah, nothing leads us to nothingness leads
us to these really, really interesting and big questions
about the nature of reality.
Yeah, you know, I love that Philomena Kunck episode
where she's asking questions to physicists and at a
certain point she's just doing a monologue and she's
saying, oh, when physicists discuss the origins of the
universe. And they say that it's possible that it
came from nothing. What you have to do is,
uh, you see this orange, you have to imagine
the orange and then imagining it not existing and
then doing that to everything that exists and then
that's nothing. It's it's hilarious.
Yeah, I mean, oh my gosh, Diane Morgan is
such a hero and I, I love all the
Philomena Kuns so much. Um, I, I really feel
actually that she's a philosopher. Yeah,
she's sort of she's sort of an unintentional philosopher.
Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
OK, so, uh, another, uh, I, I mean, this
for me is one of the most fascinating things
you explore in your book, uh, uh, that has
to do with possibilities. So, uh, I mean, of
course, we can imagine what we think are possible
things. Possible scenarios, possible futures, and things that we
deem to be impossible. But I mean, how can
we know whether something is possible or impossible? How
do we do that?
Yeah, um, well, I suppose the the way I
look at it in my book is um through
the example of eggs. So that's the food example
I've chosen for this. And um so when we
have an egg and we crack it, there's this
possibility that um it's has a double yolk as
opposed to a singular yolk. So there there is
that sense of chance or possibility there. Um, BUT
it seems quite different to the sort of possibility
that it that we crack it and there's a
chick in there or a different animal entirely. Um,
AND again, completely different, um, sense of possibility or
impossibility to cracking it and it having a double
yolk and not a double yolk. Um, SO trying
to, uh, measure or understand the differences between these
types of possibility, um, in compare in comparison with
impossible outcomes, um, is philosophically up for grabs. There
are many different, uh, ways of, of trying to
do it, um, through like. Frequency or um through
just uh reducing it to ignorance or through um
possible we
we can we can also use we can also
resort to probability and statistics, right.
Yeah, yeah. But in the question there would be,
are we putting the cart before the horse? Um,
IS it that those uh probabilities and stat statistics
are just reporting back on what the what the
possibilities are, um, rather than the, um, so they
kind of just doing the descriptive work if you
like. Um, SO. Yeah, trying to understand whether there's
actual possibilities in the world, um, is, um, yeah,
another metaphysical open question, I suppose.
Yeah, because going back to, going back to physics,
I mean, there's this idea that, that there could
be other universes if we live in a multiverse.
Of course, there could be other universes with different
laws of physics, but I mean, how can we
know that that's even possible? I mean, that could
just be impossible. I mean it's just a It's
just an idea that we have, right, and it's,
I mean, at least for now with the technological
limitations that we have, it doesn't seem to me
to even be empirically testable. So it's just, and
what, what would those alternative laws of physics even
be, you know, so.
Yeah, I mean, I so. It is also not
just me uh physical but a metaphysical question, a
way of um conceptualizing possibility through um the idea
of the the multiverse or through uh what uh
David Lewis calls possible worlds. Um, AND so we
understand possibility um via um. Them being represented um
in a world where that possible thing is actual.
So, um, but of course not all possibilities are
made equal. Some things are uh less possible than
others and some require a change in physical laws,
like you say, some require a change in logical
laws. Um, AND so. Uh, We can think of
these possible worlds um as being nearer or further
away from our one by virtue of how similar.
Um, THEY might be. Um, BUT then there's this
other question as to whether what we've deemed an
impossible world is actually just a really, really far
away world, um, in a world or rather than
a world that just is never actualized. Um, SO
we have another instance of struggling to grapple with
negativity, um, by trying to push it through this
framework of, uh, possible, um. Possible worlds. Um, BUT
yeah, the question that you ask regarding its sort
of verifiability, um, I suppose one way of thinking
about the possible worlds analysis is just as a,
a framework, a model for understanding possibility. But then
there are others who really think that they are
real, who are realists about these possible worlds. And
say that yes, there really actually are all these
different possible worlds, but they're gonna be um ultimately
completely inaccessible from our current from our actual world.
So of course they'll be unverifiable. Um AND then
um another meta metaphysical question would be, can we
really claim to know anything that is unverifiable. If
by very it's very definition, um, it's not something
that can be verified, how much credence can we
really give to it? Um, SO it depends how
helpful you think the framework is without having to
go down the realist route for understanding possibility. Um,
ESPECIALLY when we recognize that those alternative possible worlds
are always gonna be alternative to the actual world,
and we are only right here in the actual
world, and that's all we have access to.
Yeah, because I was also thinking, let's say that
a scientist makes a prediction and then it comes
out negative, that the prediction was wrong. So was
the prediction that he made a possibility, or since
it came out negative, it's just impossible? I mean,
how should we approach such a question?
Mhm. I suppose that sort of leads into quite
deterministic or almost fatalistic territory where things either are
true and actual or they're not. And there isn't
really anything in between. So on that sort of
framework you might think that there are no chances
or possibilities of any alternatives, um. And anything that
might have seemed to be possible um is just
a mere measure of our ignorance as to whether
it is or will be actual. Um, SO if
something turns out to be false, um. Is that,
does that mean that it could never ever have
been well. This is again one of those big
questions as to um whether we conflate um all
the nonactual with the impossible or whether some non
actual things can be seen as being possible um
to different extents. um AND how we measure um
that difference and articulate that difference in a reasoned
way, it's quite hard to come up with.
Yeah, so, uh, uh, changing topics, you also talk
about objectivity and subjectivity, and I guess that since
you're resorting to food analogies, this is very irrelevant
in the sense that People discuss whether, for example,
taste is merely subjective. So I mean, is it
merely subjective or what, how should we approach such
a question from a philosophical perspective?
Yeah, um, so you're right that this is one
of the themes or topics in the book that
has a far more direct relevance to food given
that taste is the prime example I think that
people appeal to in order to motivate that some
things are subjective. But this very um. Binary, um,
or distinction between the objective and the subjective is
one that I think we can challenge by looking
to the, the overlap, by looking to the gaps,
um, and also to notice whether really anything falls,
um, only on one side or the other. Um,
AND I'm not sure that there is anything or
anywhere that the subject is not, um. And therefore
not sure whether anything is really purely sub uh
objective. Um, SO, so that that dichotomy, that binary
is is one that I think is worth, um,
challenging a bit or complexifying. Um, BUT when it
comes to taste, yeah, I think even the the
way that we speak of taste has different, um.
Different connotations or different meanings to it, so, um,
some say that there is a non-subjective, um, fact
of the matter as to what a lemon or
some other food tastes like, um. Namely that a
lemon is zesty and that's like a a non-subjective
matter of taste or what it tastes like. But
then there's this other way of talking about taste
which is whether uh what our own taste for
lemon or zesty things is like and that might
be a matter of preference. So what it tastes
like versus um whether we like the taste or
what our tastes in zesty foods are, um, they
seem to be maybe different things, um, where. Um,
I think people try to appeal, I suppose, to
the latter being a kind of subjective form of
taste and the former being more of an objective,
uh, form of taste.
OK, so do you think that if I say
chocolate ice cream is the best ice cream out
there and my brother says no, it's strawberry, strawberry
ice cream that we can that we can ever
objectively tell which one of us is right.
Oh, it's an age old question, chocolate or strawberry
ice cream. Um, um, WELL, I think best for
what purpose or best for who. That's, I don't
know if there's any such notion of, um, these
values or judgments that aren't somewhat context sensitive. And
so it might be true that chocolate is best
for you. And you are correct when you utter
the phrase that chocolate ice cream is best, um,
whereas your brother, it might be that what is
best for him is strawberry, and so it's true
when he says that strawberry is is best for
him. So making things context sensitive is a. It
is important to know um what we mean when
we're talking about in
in in that context, both of us would be
right because both er claims would be true, but
only in a subjective sense, correct.
Well, I suppose, er. You can also have best
talking about bestness um for a different for a
specific purpose and that purpose might be a non
subjective purpose. um, SO yeah, I'd it's it's a
it's a tricky one, that people love to, you
know, riff about in order to, um. Say oh
look, everything is relative or whatever, you know, it's
a kind of a cliched. Thing to to spout.
Um, BUT I think a way of making that
that cliche of everything is relative more um. Intellectually
interesting is not to always make that relativity relative
to a specific subject, but to think more about
the a wider context of things and um what
role things are playing um because it's within, it's
for a certain role that something might be best
for um. So yeah, it's not always just about
the subject dictating um bestness for themselves. It's it's
sometimes there's far more to a context than that.
So, but it's one thing to talk about food
preferences, but if, for example, we are talking about
moral values, or at least this is something that
people tend to do, I would imagine that perhaps
certain some philosophers would disagree with what is common
sense, let's say. But when, when people talk about
moral values, they tend to think about them as
being special. All kinds of values that are different
from just food tastes or even sometimes aesthetic values.
They, they think that there's something more to them,
something more serious or objective to them, something more
concrete to them. So I mean, do you think
that, uh, do you think that we should approach
moral values as being different from other kinds of
values?
Mhm. All the big questions, um. Yeah, I mean,
in the book I discussed this with respect to
cheese, so I still bring it back to food.
Um, AND thinking of cheese, which people do have
moral, um, positions on because it's a, a food
product. Um, AND so they have this negative value
judgment about it with respect to its ethical status.
Um, AND that might interact with the aesthetic judgment
of it too. Um, AND it might go like
both ways. So I think there are ways that
our judgments interact with each other such that we
can't always sharply distinguish, um, what is only a
moral matter, what is only an aesthetic matter, um,
what is only a political matter. I think they,
they all, um. Inter are intertwined in some way,
um. But whether those values are always only in
the eye of the beholder or the person doing
the judging or whether they track um like you
mentioned, some sort of universal standard of what is
objectively good um for all people, all times, all
places, that's that's another open question, but, um, as
you can probably tell from my answers to some
of your other questions, I don't really think that
there is some like. Recipe book I suppose um
of reality that fixes any of these things, um,
that's beyond us, um, and that we're actually some
of the creative agents, um, in, in constituting those
values, whether they're moral, political, aesthetic, and so on.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, me personally, and I've had
also this conversation on the show with other philosophers,
but I've also talked about it with anthropologists, sociologists,
psychologists, but because my background is more in science,
it's easier for me to fall more on the
camp of moral anti-realism because it's easier for me
to understand, for example, how the values in the
Particular society develop in particular ecological, economic, uh, socioeconomic,
uh, political contexts, and then just to look at
diversity across societies and think, oh no, there's nothing
really objective about this, it's just, I mean contextual
or whatever you want to call it, but there
are many philosophers who even if they have that
kind of more anthropological and social science knowledge, they
disagree and they say that there's still something that
is more objective to morality, you know. Um, INTERESTING
that
that's the one, that morality is the thing that
pulls people towards some sense of objectivity. Um, YEAH,
I'm, I'm not sure if that's, that's the way
I go. I think I do end up quite,
um. Nihilistic almost when I'm. Digging and digging away
at at reality, trying to make sense of things,
trying to, you know, I think it's comforting to
be able to have something to point to like
oh that that's the book of of reality and
we can appeal to these rules and those values
and um to, I don't know, give some fixed
ground to it. But I'm not sure really that
there is anything that is so fixed, that is
so beyond um. Malleability and uh construction that we've
played a a role in in constituting so um
yeah, I'm interested also to hear how um the
anthropologists, the sociologists, the scientists answer these questions differently.
I find that fascinating. Um, IF there is a
kind of theme that you found or convergence or
lack of convergence across these disciplines,
I, I, I mean it depends. Some of them
just, uh, say that they don't know because they
don't have enough philosophical training to ask to answer
the question of whether. Moral values are objective or
not, so some of them just refuse to answer
that question and they say it falls outside of
their expertise. But then you also have philosophers like,
for example, Dr. Owen Flanagan, who is very much
a moral anti-realist, but because he's heavily influenced by
anthropology and other fields like that, so. You know,
but, but then, but then, yeah, there are also
psychologists and anthropologists who claim in a straightforward way,
no, there's no objectivity to moral values at all.
I mean, if you just study human psychology or
anthropology, if you study different societies, it's pretty obvious
that uh moral values are context dependent, so. And
that's, yeah, that's the answer. So, there's a variability
also among scientists and among philosophers, and some philosophers
are, uh, uh, are very much scientifically minded and
some scientists are a little bit more philosophically minded,
you know, so. There is a variability. I personally
tend to be more convinced by moral anti-realism than
moral realism, but that's just my position through that
I got through years of talking about that topic
with philosophers and scientists, so
yeah, fair enough.
OK, so let me ask you another kind of
question. So is it possible for us to know
anything at all? I mean, and this is sort
of the radical skeptic position. I mean the radical
skeptics would say no, it's not possible for us
to know anything at all, or at least to
know anything at all with any degree of certainty,
so. Uh, WHAT is your approach to that? Um,
IT actually relates a bit to what we were
just discussing on objectivity and subjectivity, because it might
be that, um. Some people might think that subjectivity
or context sensitivity or having values um that run
all the way down through our uh through our
through our knowledge formation um actually might get in
the way of saying that we can know anything.
um BUT I don't I don't think that has
to be the case and the things that might,
uh, it just actually clarifies what sort of things
it is that we can know. If we require.
We'll set our standards so high to require some
sort of untouched or untouchable reasoning, um, in order
to gain knowledge, then yeah, gonna lead you to
skepticism because it might, you might find that nothing
can meet those standards. Um, SO again I think
that. Uh, CONTEXT is something that is helpful, um,
to appeal to what it is that we want
to know something for. So, like, um, I know
that, uh, that this water will quench my thirst,
um, but maybe I don't know radically that that
I'm not dreaming or not a brain in a
vat, um, but that's not gonna prevent me from
drinking the water, um, so. Like there are certain
contexts within different forms of knowledge or er standards
for knowledge um are the ones that are salient,
so right now I'm gonna drink some water. And
I, I, that's quenched my thirst. So, um. That's
kind of, yeah, different bits of knowledge player different
roles and have different standards depending on the context,
I think.
Yeah, this, this at least to some extent gets
me thinking about how, for example, Western science deals
with a more traditional uh or how do you
call it, indigenous forms of knowledge in the sense
that uh we tend to think. That any kind
of knowledge that is not a proper science is
not real knowledge and for example, if in a
tribe people instead of using a system of classification
for biological organisms. uh, LIKE, for example, all kingdom
and family and genus and species and all of
that, they just classify them in terms of all
the, uh, I can eat these plants. Those plants
are non-edible. I can use them for medicine or
something like that, that, that is not. Real, uh,
science and the, and sometimes people even go all
the way to say that, that, that's not, uh,
true, uh, in the sense that that's not real
knowledge. The only real knowledge out there is knowledge
that is scientifically established. I mean, how do you
approach such questions?
Yeah, I mean, you've given some really good examples
as to how um Western society kind of think
is imposing its uh. Epistemology, I suppose, how it
understands knowledge onto um other other ways of knowing
um and dismissing other ways of knowing um because
of its kind of colonial um way of like
understanding reality. Um. And I think that, you know,
that is really unjust and inaccurate and um. Not
gonna lead us to the fullest pictures of reality.
And so yeah, there are. Different ways of knowing.
And trying to privilege one way above another. Is
already to have um. Set the scale in favor
of one form over another by using the conditions
of what classifies as knowledge as um, assuming that
that works better than another. Sorry, I've articulated that
so badly, but using the example that you mentioned
earlier with unverifiability, you know. If that is um
if what makes something verifiable is only through some
sort of Western uh style of scientific experiments, then
you've already um set the scales against anything that
doesn't meet that sort of standard or works in
a completely different way. Um, AND so yeah, it's
worth challenging. Um, THOSE, those assumptions that we're making
as to what qualifies as, um. A condition for
for knowledge, um, by learning that there are alternative
ways of knowing, embodied ways of knowing, indigenous ways
of knowing.
Yeah, and it's interesting because I mean if you
follow, if we follow the strictly the scientific script
of only believing that the only true knowledge is
the one that we can empirically test, then we,
I mean people could even make a case for
dismissing things like logic and mathematics because I mean,
you can't empirically test logics, for example, right?
Yeah. Yeah, I think there's there's definitely a sort
of double standard thing that goes on when we
dismiss certain disciplines or um epistemologies as mystical, when
I don't know what's more mystical than as you
described thinking about like, uh, maths or logic. These
are these are quite mystical. Um, AND there's always
some, I suppose, leap of faith into uh. Into
a certain framework that you can't back up by
virtue of something independent because that justification would already
have come from within the framework that you're working
with. And so there is no. External kind of
uh place that we can judge things um a
view from nowhere I guess um that we can
judge things against each other. We're always working with
what we've got in a way and um there's.
Yeah, so, so yeah, I'll stop there. I know
I'm, I'm babbling.
No, no, no worries at all. Well, I mean,
let me ask you this then, and going back
to a food example. Um, WHAT is the distinction
between a potato and a chip? I mean, are,
are these two different things? I mean, when we
turn a potato into a chip, has it transformed
in any sort of relevant way in the sense
that we can talk about two distinct entities? Is
it the same entity but just in two different
forms? I mean, how should we approach this question?
Yeah, so back into the playground of metaphysics, is
it? Um, SO yeah, in, yeah, in the book,
um, I, I use this example of the potato
and the chip to articulate, um, uh, another metaphysical
puzzle of, uh, co-location and constitution. Um, SO we
might think that. There's a question as to whether
there are two things there, where, where the chip
is, the chip itself and also what it's made
of, namely the potato. Um, AND it might be
that we can find differences between the chip and
the potato. They might have different persistence conditions, things
that they can survive. Um, FOR example, we could
squish the the chip, entirely, flatten it. The potato
is still there, it's just in a different arrangement,
but the chip is destroyed. And because of this
distinction that we can make between the chip and
the potato that one can survive something that the
other doesn't, or we can ascribe properties to the
chip that we don't, to the potato or vice
versa, makes them, makes it seem like there's more
than one thing there. But then that means that
we've got two things co-locating, um, the chip and
the potato in the same place at the same
time. And um this, you know, creates quite a
a strange metaphysical picture, um. But er if if
they're distinct and so yeah, I think that it's
another one of those um puzzles that in philosophy
that aren't really resolved. There are different ways of
trying to um understand um this puzzle, um, but
it's not one that I put forward my own
unique um uh resolution to.
Uh, I mean, if we change the composition of
things, does that necessarily impact their identity? So for
example, I mean, giving an example that is not
food related. So let's say that little by little
I started replacing body parts with artificial parts. With
robot parts and I would become a cyborg, but
then I would go on until I replaced every
single body part of mine with a robot part.
I mean, would there still be enough Ricardo in
the robot for it to be Ricardo, or at
a certain point, would it just be a robot
and there would be no Ricardo
there? The classic metaphysical puzzle, um, sometimes known as
the the ship of Theseus because that's kind of
precisely what happens with the ship is, um, that
plank by plank it gets, uh, replaced. And you
could even think about those planks that are taken
out being rebuilt. Um, SOMEWHERE else and so then
which, which ship is the ship of Theseus. Um,
SO, but you know, in, in the book I
do do this with food because I do, I
do all of the analogies and the examples to
food, um, with respect to, uh, soup, I think
I do it with, so replacing bit by bit
the soup, um, having like some sort of perpetual
soup or perpetual stew and trying to understand identity
over time and identity through change, um. Because, um,
everything does change, you know, we're, you, you talk
about your yourself like we're changing all the time,
we're kind of shedding bits and, um, we're in
eating as well, we're ingesting things and they, I
mean even it seems like every 7 years, every
single atom in our body gets changed. It's a
different atom, so you know.
Yeah, so, so food um and how it integrates
into our being and how we then excrete some
as well and is one way of really showing
how all the time we are changing. So change
seems to be something that's unavoidable. And yet if
our identities, as your question asks, um, rests on
things being fixed, like trying to pinpoint. The planks
of Theseus's ship or the atoms that constitute you,
um, then, uh, nothing really would persist through time,
um, or through change. And it makes us really
question the very basic, uh, building blocks of reality
as to whether they're even building blocks at all.
um, BECAUSE blocks kind of give the impression that
things are static, um. So an alternative way to
make sense of this flux in reality is to
kind of let go of this uh Lego like
um formation of reality, things being static, static things,
um, and instead embrace what is known as a
a process ontology or a process metaphysics, um, where.
Where we have a more kind of horizontal look
of um across change um in order to capture
what our identity, um, is. So yeah, I think
food is one of these great. Uh, EVERYDAY examples
that when we think a little bit harder about
it, it can challenge our most basic assumptions about
reality and about the self, about the boundaries of
the self and about the building blocks or processes,
um, in reality.
Yeah, that bit about substance ontology versus process ontology
is very interesting because I mean we can even
apply a complex systems approach to human psychology and
instead of thinking about even things as basic as
identity or the self as having some sort of
essence to it that I mean what happens is
that there's not an essence. Or a substance there
it's, it's rather a process and it's always, it's
ever changing, of course, even if I change psychologically,
I keep identifying as Ricardo, so, but it's not
because I have a psychological essence that doesn't change.
It's just that I mean I have this sort
of, perhaps we could think about it more of
a sort of. Cultural construct where people have given
me this name Ricardo and whatever happens uh in
my brain or even the rest of my body
over time uh doesn't prevent me from still identifying
as. Myself, but it's not because I have a
psychological essence in me, even, but that's a very,
I mean, the substance ontology is very prevalent in
the more, in more mainstream psychology and Western science
where, for example, we tend to think about. Psychological
traits as being sort of as substances, as things
that we have in our psychology that even if
they change, there's still an unchanged core to them,
you know, something along those lines, right.
Yeah, I think that the the whole concept of
identity and how we identify and what we identify
with and what it is that keeps us persisting
as the same thing over time and over change
is is really fascinating. And um it may well
be. That, um, processual views are better equipped to
provide answers um to those questions than a than
a substance ontology or a thing ontology that tries
to locate, um, identity and something fixed when, you
know, nothing really is is that fixed.
Yeah, OK, so look, I have one final question,
and of course I couldn't end the interview without
asking you this because it's like even in philosophy
it's the most important question ever. I mean, even
Camus said that maybe the most important question is
whether we should commit suicide or not, but I
think this is actually the most important question. I
mean, should pineapple go on pizza or not?
Oh, that's so funny. Um, SHOULD is maybe. Uh,
THE, not the words that I would use. It,
it could. Um, I prefer it not to. Um,
SO, oh, I don't know. If you're a purist
about like what constitutes, uh, a legitimate pizza topping,
then you might be anti, anti pineapple. But again,
in like relevant to the previous question, things change,
norms change. What becomes a legit, um, pizza topping
is again, uh, something that we can um. Influence,
so the more people that put it on on
on as a topping. Yeah, maybe the more it
becomes accepted as as a legitimate topic.
Oh, so you're you're one of those pineapple haters.
Is that it? Oh,
no, I'm just, I'm just quite despite having written
a book, uh, with food as all the examples.
I'm quite a basic food eater and I'm so.
Um, YEAH, I'd say that it, that pineapple takes
me too far out of my comfort zone for
what I enjoy in a pizza.
Well, so, so you know, when there's doubt, I
always tend to defer to the experts and uh
I've seen evidence of Italian people eating pineapple pizza.
So I think there's enough there to make a
case for er er pineapple er er a case
for that pineapple can go on pizza and it's
still a proper pizza.
So yeah, I mean it certainly is going on
pizza. The question that you originally posed was should
it? It is happening, it is happening, so we
might as well get used to it. OK,
so, uh, I mean, unfortunately, we ended up not
answering the most important question ever, but anyway, that's
philosophy for you, I guess.
So they get asked, but maybe they don't get
answered. Yeah.
OK, so the book is again What's in the
Donut Hole and Other Philosophical Food for Thought. I
will of course be leaving a link to it
in the description of the interview. And Dr. Finn,
apart from the book, would you like to tell
people where they can find you and your work
on the internet?
Oh, OK, cool, thank you. Um, SO, yeah, the
book is published by Icon. It came out in
May 2026, which is last month, uh, for now.
Um, AND yeah, that can be found on Icon's
website. Otherwise, I don't have any social media, but
I do have a website myself that links to
lots of my other work. Um, SO this book
and also my previous book that I edited called
Women of Ideas. Um, MY website is www.ski Finn.com.
Um, YOU spell my name, S U K I
F I N N. Um, AND yeah, so from
there you can find, um, my theoretical academic work
as well as my public engagement stuff as well
as music. Um, SO, um, yeah, that's where you
can find me.
Great, and look, I really love the book and
if you're open to it, uh, I would love
to do an episode with you on Philomena Kunk.
So. 00 my God, I am absolutely open to
that. Oh yeah, she's such a hero of mine.
Um, IF you're, if you're listening, Diane Morgan, I,
I love you. Um, SO yeah, OK, cool. So
let's plan for, for a Philomena Kunk exploring the
philosophy of Philomena Kunk on the dissenter. I'm well
up for that.
OK, great. So thank you so much for, for
doing this. It's been really fun and informative. So
thank you so much.
Oh no, it's been my pleasure. Thank you so
much for having me back and for engaging with
the book. I really appreciate it. It's been great
having to talk to you again.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Sverggoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith
and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.